[Music]
what is a pest
you're annoying neighbor or sibling
no
a pest is an organism that eats or
damages crop plants that are grown in
agriculture
for example
slugs eating lettuce in my garden
pests can be controlled using pesticides
or by introducing other species also
known as biological control
pesticides are natural or synthetic
chemicals that are sprayed on crops
they include
insecticides that control insects
fungicides that control fungi
and herbicides that control weeds other
plants that are not supposed to grow
with the crop
pesticides can be sprayed all over a
field using industrial machinery like
tractors or planes
or in specific areas by humans
why do you think this person is wearing
so much protection while spraying crops
with pesticides
pesticides can be toxic to other
organisms not just the organisms they
aim to control
one example of this is ddt
dgt was used as an insecticide in the
mid 20th century to control mosquitoes
which spread malaria
a potentially fatal disease amongst
humans
however ddt was found to accumulate in
food chains
also known as bioaccumulation
the molecules of ddt did not break down
but instead were stored in the bodies of
organisms and passed on when those
organisms were eaten
the ddt became more concentrated in the
higher levels of the food chain
the effect on birds of prey was
catastrophic
it caused them to lay eggs with thin
shells that broke easily when the birds
incubated them
this led to a fall in the birth rate of
birds of prey and a massive decrease in
their populations
the use of ddt was eventually banned as
a result
through the process of evolution and
natural selection some pests become
resistant to pesticides
they survive and reproduce
the overuse of pesticides has led to an
increasing number of those organisms
which means that some pesticides are now
useless
apart from using pesticides which is
also known as chemical control
farmers can use biological control
mechanisms
can you think what that could be
biological control is the use of a
natural predator of the organism you
wish to control
for example aphids or green flies are
herbivores that feed on many human crops
aphids are eaten by ladybirds
ladybirds could be added to an
environment to control the number of
aphid pests
sometimes this method of control works
well
however the introduction of a new
species to an environment can have
unexpected effects
one example of this the hawaiian cane
toad
it was introduced in australia to
control the population of the cane
beetle a pest that damaged sugarcane
crops
however the hawaiian cane toad had
little effect on the cane beetle
population
instead cane toads reproduced rapidly
and spread across australia as they had
no natural predators
it's now considered a pest species
itself
and has been blamed for the extinction
of some endemic species
so now you know how pests can be
controlled to allow farmers to grow the
maximum amount of crops possible
if you want to learn more about
intensive farming methods and why they
use pesticides and fertilizers watch
this video
if you liked the video give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe comment
below if you have any questions why not
check out our fusco app as well until
next time